whoa all right hi everyone as Jett said
my name is Jenna and I'll be talking to
you today about the linguistic
relativity of programming languages so I
know from people asking me so what are
you talking about that the term
linguistic relativity not exactly the
most obvious what that is don't worry
I'll get there first a little bit more
information on me I was fortunate enough
to be part of the fall 2012 batch of
hacker school which is an awesome
three-month program in New York City for
becoming a better programmer they have a
great set of social rules which makes it
a wonderful environment which to learn
grow ask questions that was fantastic
and now all my fur I am a friend of
engineer at bitly I currently live in
Brooklyn and you can find me on the
internet twitter at Zygon vector and I
am Jenna Z on github all right since I'm
a good bit as in I made you a bitly link
bit least last JZ - just comfy you those
are the slides follow along if you want
send them to your friends cool all right
now for the good stuff first I'll
explain to you exactly what this
linguistic relativity thing is then say
hmm does this apply to programming
languages
spoiler alert it does absolutely no talk
and then I'll move on to not the first
person to say hmm forgive my languages
and linguistic relativity do these maybe
have something to do with each other so
I'll tell you what some other people
have
and then go on to say how the how
linguistic relativity does apply to
programming languages and kind of
imperil l the implications of the
application so linguistic relativity
once upon a time there were two men one
named Edward Sapir and the other named
Benjamin Whorf now the pure hypothesis
is the hypothesis it's a bit of a
misnomer because worth did all the
hypothesizing and Sapir was just his
mentor who did not really have much to
say on the issue but this is history
so this sapir-whorf hypothesis thing it
says that the languages we speak either
determine which is the strong form or
influence which is the weaker form the
way that we think now no one really
believes in the strong form this
linguistic determinism because it's kind
of naive to believe that we are wholly
constrained by the languages we speak we
do have the ability to reason about
things that we don't exactly have words
for that we can't really explain
however the weaker form that's
linguistic relativity this weaker form
while still a little controversial it's
easier to see how it might apply how the
words that we have the way that we have
to see things might at least color our
world and an example of this a classic
example is the words that we have for
colors so the colors exist on a spectrum
right but we have a discrete amount of
discrete words that parse this
continuous color space so you know the
way the weave in English think about
this this space that I have up here
which this might be the only valid use
of gradients of the presentation it's we
have green and blue there's two ways we
think about this as green and blue while
the barrier between
- might be controversial between you and
your friends there is indeed a line
however if we were to have a third word
that fell in between green and blue say
grew then that we'd have three ways of
thinking about this three lines or two
lines that that trisect
of this spectrum but this is a jeaious
con for you that does linguistic
relativity applied to programming
languages I I think so I'd like to
propose that the programming languages
we know strongly influence the way we
think about programming this is strongly
influenced not quite the you know lazy
influence that spoken languages have on
thought and this strong influence
follows from a key difference that I see
between programming languages and spoken
languages and that is that programming
languages create and manipulate our
space rather than just describe it this
is not the case with spoken languages we
can only describe the space with our
spoken languages we are not wizards from
Harry Potter I can't say akio chair and
it'll come flying through the air
towards me that's not how the real world
works but you know it kind of feels like
when you're programming kind of feels
like you do have magical powers
sometimes because it's the language
itself that is manipulating and even
creating the space without programming
languages there is no space in which
your your reasoning about there's no
data or whatever so furthermore animals
don't have language like we as humans do
but they are capable of interacting with
and manipulating their environment so as
I said I'm not the first person to say
hmm programming languages and thought do
they intersect at all do they have
influence on each other Kenneth Iverson
who
one of the creators of the APL
programming language uses symbols if
you're not familiar with it sad that
programming languages offer important
advantages as tools of thought
therefore suggesting okay well if it's a
tool of thought we're going to have it
will have some influence on the way that
we're thinking about the programming
space more notably and maybe infamously
Paul Graham had an argument in his paper
or speech turned paper beating the
averages this argument it's come to be
known as the blob paradox the crux of
which is that some programming languages
are more powerful than others and he
motivates this argument by supposing a
fake very average programming language
called blub-blub programmers are very
happy programming in blub they can do
whatever they want to do in blub it's
it's enough for them they can get their
stuff done and they look down at
programmers in weaker languages or
languages that they see a speaker and
are like how could you ever use that it
doesn't have this construct how do you
do anything similarly they look up to
other stronger languages Paul Graham
says list is the strongest language and
he he loves Lisp so blood programmers
look up to stronger languages and
they're like well I'm pretty happy using
blub list can't be that much better can
it it might have some other things in
there but I don't quite understand them
I don't use them and if I don't use them
how important can they be because I can
get everything I need to do done using
blub and the list programmers look down
at blub and the weaker language just
like the blood programmer looks down at
that weaker language we're concretely
Paul Graham sees Python Python Java C
and pearl as blobs and he wonders how
can they get how can these programmers
of these languages get anything done in
these languages who thinks without
hygienic macros
I mean similarly I don't know what
macros are I'm a mere blub Script
programmer right but he does a really
good job explaining them enough to say
maybe I should you know look into that
it seems pretty cool
PG goes on to say that programmers these
programmers and blubber satisfied with
whatever language they happen to use
because their language dictates the way
they think about programs he says he
knows this from his own experience when
he started programming in basic which
shouldn't have recursion but he didn't
miss it because he said he thought in
basic Dijkstra had some stronger saltier
things to say about people who started
off learning basic he says that they are
mentally mutilated beyond hope of
regeneration and while this might have
been said to prove a points of some sort
really like mentally mutilated beyond
hope you know no Paul Graham was able to
rise above his basic roots and learn
Lisp the most powerful programming
language in the world so with this I
would like to slightly amend my original
proposal and say that we are influenced
by the constructs and idioms of the most
powerful program programming language we
know not the languages themselves or the
language we are using at the time so
what do we do to really you know
optimize for everyone's maximal mind
expansion well there are three
differences that I see three more
differences I suppose then I see between
programming languages and natural
languages which motivate this amended
proposal the first of which is that we
can learn more programming languages and
how to program in them idiomatically now
this is very hard especially for adults
it's very hard for adults to learn
and you spoken language you can study
one for years and years and never become
fluent nonetheless even proficient you
might forget it this is because your
your brains are no longer plastic your
neurons don't don't have the capability
of learning things like you used to and
furthermore if you don't learn any
spoken language by a certain age you're
doomed to never learn any this really is
not the case with programming languages
assuming most of us did not learn
programming languages when we were three
but we were capable of learning at least
one assume most of you care do know
JavaScript so we do have the capability
to learn new languages and you can learn
another one and within six months you're
likely to be pls proficient and able to
make cool things if you want to so an
example of this from my personal
experience is I started programming as a
junior in university and for some reason
in like still in 2010 they still decide
that they're going to teach new
programmers how to program in Java and
with that they only taught us loops and
I was pretty happy you know mutating
data and arrays just with loops I felt
like it was super powerful I felt like I
can do anything
then a year later I took a class in
algorithms and data structures and with
that came python and with Python came
it's idiomatic list comprehension and I
was able to learn list comm branch and
pretty quickly especially the more
simple constructs felt kind of like
looping eventually I was able to pick up
the more complicated constructs and you
know it was it was pretty good then I
went to hacker school and started off
very happy in my imperative programming
language world but I made friends who
were super hardcore into functional
languages and they're like do you
even mad bro and it's like what's that
so I eventually picked up map took a
little bit of time for me to wrap my
head around this functional and
mutability stuff I eventually got it and
now I choose map out of the toolbox
first as much as I can alright so the
second way that programming languages
and natural languages spoken languages
are different is that we can implement
the constructs of more powerful
languages programming languages in
whatever language we happen to be using
at the time this really does not happen
in spoken languages you can't say oh
yeah well I have I went to Germany and I
heard this really cool word and I'm
gonna keep using it all the time and so
here's a dictionary of all those cool
words that I learned when I was in
Germany use them please I'm gonna be
using them so yeah cool that doesn't
really happen in spoken languages but it
kind of happens in programming languages
it's classically happens with libraries
but more popularly especially in
JavaScript we have source
transformations pre compilers and the
like so they steal one said we should
now think of a language design for being
a pattern for language designs a tool
for making more tools of the same kind
and I agree with that a ubiquitous I
guess example of this is underscore or
lodash helps stabilize what we can use
regardless of the ES spec implementation
in our users browsers which it's a quirk
of the meta situation around JavaScript
that this really is the thing that we
have to worry about but that's besides
the point
underscore allows me to use map whenever
I want because you know I love map now
it doesn't necessarily I don't need it
to be on the array prototype necessarily
just as long as I can like do map II
things that's all I really need
another example of this that debuted at
je s Kampf us as far as I know is a
sweet je s we have macros now genic
macros yay we can craft language we've
always wanted or no longer confined by
blob scripts the lisp is now or breasts
so never used it I'm gonna try to in the
future and third example of this is you
know we have these portents of future
equi scripts but there they're still in
the future and you know you're all
eating for classes and generators and a
read comprehension that can be now if we
use translation for features in future
specs such as you can use tracer yes
next we're no longer restricted by the
language we have now we can bring in
those things that we've seen in other
languages that we miss if we want to and
thirdly so I just deleted two
programming languages are it synthetic
and we can change them if we want to we
make up programming languages which
means they can be whatever we want them
to be or whatever our standards bodies
want them to be this is not really the
case with spoken languages spoken
languages evolved over hundreds of years
with no regulation leads to quirks and
irregularities and I know we all love to
talk about the quirks and regularities
in JavaScript but guys we have it pretty
good especially compared to English
furthermore spoken languages tend to not
catch on we have there's Esperanto but
really do you know any Esperanto
speakers no cuz it's no more niche thing
it's short anecdote as a as a kid I used
to think that spoken languages like
English were indeed standardized by a
group of very important smart people
sitting in a room that's not the case
with spoken languages but
I really don't know what goes on in tc39
so that might was well be what's going
on so that we can if we are powerful
enough submit proposals to JavaScript or
whatever programming language for using
and this standardization is important
because of the differences between
computers and humans computers can't
really tolerate the ambiguity in
language that makes things like puns
possible so you know we lose that but we
also get less quirks in our languages so
that's cool example of synthetic
languages changing as I mentioned well
JavaScript now has array and map in it
and eventually we'll get a great
comprehension and generators that's cool
I know how to use a read comprehension
generators not quite something I know
how to use yet I've read about them
still a little mystical to me but I
trust that of like many other people a
little bunch I'll actually be able to
use them idiomatically and it'll be
awesome
so guy still also said something along
the lines of that languages that can't
easily grow will die and yeah I think so
if if we all go off and no other
programming languages and JavaScript
doesn't really have what we wanted to
have we might eventually defect go off
write something else oh yeah like I
really want macros I have to guess I
have to go like write closure or
something but we need you guys and
writing JavaScript so we need JavaScript
to grow furthermore I like to say that
growth allows for more rapid growth
yes it's tautology o'clock already but
what I mean is that for example like
once we get he has six things like
generators we can write more efficient
and concise and idiomatic
things that we also miss things that
might be an es seven
like async/await Elsa read this great
article recently if it was a blog post
about CSP communicating sequential
processes cordoning going and also
enclosures core async I don't understand
them I'll be the first to admit when I
don't understand something as you guys
know but you know people want that and
if they want that it's not in JavaScript
then what are they gonna do you know
they they want to be able to write these
things I think and have them in the
language that they're writing so all
right well what do we do we could all go
off and learn closure script and come
back next year it'll be C ljs 2015 or
you we all could go off learn new
languages stay polyglot it'll make you a
better programmer if you know a large
array of languages thank cool things in
them and bring them back to the
community and share with your friends
and your fellow programmers and those
who don't know JavaScript and make
JavaScript great I think out of all of
these these three opportunities that we
have I think that the second option
creating libraries translation polyfills
is the best it's the most democratic we
all can do it and it'll teach you about
the core components of the of your
favorite concept in in other languages
furthermore the the JavaScript community
has a very wide array of people of
different abilities many of which no
other languages few of which have clout
with ACMA so that's really all we have
to do we can write libraries if we want
to see something if we want to use
something but no another another
ramification of this talk could be all
right well let's have one language to
rule them all put everything we need
into the one language that everyone uses
well that's not good either because
there's a reason we use the languages
that we use they evolved out of certain
circumstances and
why we use them there's reason we have
many languages so let's keep JavaScript
weird alright
you